est ce la fin de l'ère et tories au tc
le club tourangeau va en effet changer
de statut juridique pour tenter de se
sortir de ses problèmes financiers
ainsi avant le début de l'été le tfc
sera devenue une société coopérative
d'intérêt collectif
en clair particuliers collectivités et
entreprises pourront entrer au capital
du club
explications de lucas chopin et romain
delville et si vous deveniez en partie
propriétaire du tours football club
cela devrait être possible d'ici
quelques jours avec la création d'une
société coopérative d'intérêt collectif
et c'est jean luc dayan entre autres
anciens présidents des clubs de nantes
et de lens qui a été missionné par le
tfc pour la mise en place du projet il a
expérimenté le procédé avec succès sur
le club de bastia il ya quatre ans
guillaume bart et moi même allons
rencontrer un certain nombre d'acteurs
ce soit niveau des collectivités que ce
soit au niveau des entreprises que ce
soit au niveau des anciens salariés pour
voir si on arrive dans un délai qu'on
s'est fixés d'à peu près deux mois à à
réunir entre 1 et 2 millions d'euros
enfin le plus c'est le mieux l'objectif
est de laisser derrière le club la
descente aux enfers de la ligue 2 vers
le national 3 et d'un nouveau faire du
tfc un club professionnel pour ce faire
tout le monde pourra en devenir
actionnaire
le moyen plus simple évidemment ça sera
de créer sur le site du club ce qu'on va
faire à très très bientôt une
possibilité de d'accéder à la fiche
d'engagement de l'imprimer et de l'or de
la renvoyer soit par mail soit par
courrier au club tout le monde a droit
de jouer au football tout le monde a
droit de galles il aussi dans notre
projet tout le monde a droit de
participer à l'actionnariat populaire au
tours fc
ce projet compte parmi les engagements
de campagne de l'équipe d'emmanuel denis
aujourd'hui la mairie de tours se
réjouit de cet aboutissement et annonce
un futur investissement de la ville dans
le club la ville sera présente aux côtés
du club mais parce que la ville parce
que un club
c'est pas la propriété d'un homme un
club ce n'est pas la propriété d'un état
souverain
un club c'est un territoire un club ce
sont des intérêts collectifs c'est pas
la somme d'intérêts particuliers
le prix de l'action devrait avoisiner
les 50 euros
d'autres questions demeurent comme celle
de la place de l'actuel président jean
marc est ori au sein du club